When you're using vacuum power, moving water,
or compressing air, chances are it's being
done with some type of a pump. We'll need
one for future projects, so in this video
we're building a PVC hand pump, from scratch,
that will do all three.
To start this project, you'll need these PVC
parts from your local hardware store. The
1" pipe will become the plunger piston, and
we can start working on that first. You can
see this 1" pipe is a very close fit when
pushed inside the larger tube. There's just
a slight gap between the two, but in just
a minute they'll be perfectly air tight. I
chose to use a few pieces of two by four to
hold this piece in place over the blade of
a table saw. Let's measure out 2 marks from
the end of the pipe, at 1", and another at
2". You can see here that I've adjusted the
blade so that when it's cutting into the pipe,
it shouldn't cut any deeper than halfway through
the plastic. At this point we can get the
blade spinning, and hold the pipe in place
with one hand, while using the other hand
to carefully rotate the tubing. This should
result in a little groove all the way around
the pipe.Now let's repeat that at the 2" mark
as well, and now we should have 2 clean, and
uniform grooves like these. The grooves are
cut so that we can seat 2 rubber o-rings in
place, and when they're fitted snug, they
should be just slightly higher than the surface
of the tube. While we're here, let's seal
this tube with a little PVC glue and a 1"
plug. Now the plug might be tight, so just give
it a few taps with a rubber mallet to encourage
it all the way in. Now let's clean up the
piston by wiping away the excess glue, and
use a bit of sand paper to smooth down the
sides of the pipe. I'm using 220 grit sandpaper,
and you can see it cleans everything up nicely
and gives the piston a smooth finish. Now
this piece of pipe only needs to be 26" long,
so we can cut two 4-1/2" pieces from the top
to create some handles that we'll use later
on. I painted all the fittings and adaptors
black, while the tubing got painted blue,
except for the piston of course. Now let's
go ahead and cement it together. First we'll
need to glue the coupling to the bottom reducer
bushing, then glue the bigger tube into that,
making sure it pushes all the way to the bottom.
We can go ahead and cement the handle together,
but don't attach it yet, just set it to the
side. We need to insert the piston first,
so use plenty of lubricating jelly around
the o-rings and the pieces should connect
together with just a push and a twist. Finally,
we can cement the cap on the top, and the
hydraulic piston is complete. Now, if you're
wondering how the top cap was made, I just
took a regular slip cap and drilled a hole
in the center with a 1-3/8" Forstner bit.
The #320 O-Ring fit nicely inside that, and
I used a little more lubricating jelly around
the ring
Now you can see the
piston sticks out just a couple of inches,
and this is the place where we're gonna
attach our handle. When it's glued on tight,
it should have just the smallest gap of clearance
when the piston bottoms out. Well now we have
a piston. Let's turn it into a pump. To do
that, we'll be using two of these one-way
check valves that were made in a previous
project. The threaded bushing at the bottom
of the piston is designed to accept a 3/4"
nipple, and the threaded Tee fitting screws
onto that. If you try this yourself, make
sure to use something like thread tape to
ensure the connections end up water tight.
Our two check valves can connect in-line with
the bottom of the Tee, and because they're
threaded, we'll have the convenient option
of switching, or replacing them any time we
want. At this point, you should have a completely
operational water pump, ready to test out.
It's very important that the valves point
the right direction so that when the piston
is pulled up, water flows in, and when it's
pushed down, it flows out the opposite
side. Alright, let's see what this thing can
do. If we place something like a balloon over
the outflow valve and begin to pump, you can
see the balloon blows up on every downward
stroke. If you try adding additional pipes
to the valves, you'll be able to leverage
the pump with your feet. I tried putting balloons
on each valve so you can see how every cycle
sucks air from the red balloon, and pumps
it into the yellow. When all the air gets used
up, the balloon gets sucked inside. Now this
opens up the option to using the system as
a vacuum pump, and we can get a rough idea
on how strong it is by blocking the valves
from both directions. This time when the piston
is pulled back, it creates a strong vacuum
in the chamber, which you can clearly see
when we let go. For more variety, I tried
converting this into a vertical pump, and
was able to pump 3 gallons of water in about
a minute. Each cycle seems to pump just a
little over 2 cups of water, and I found that
by leveraging the pump with my feet, I could
double the flow rate, and move over 5 gallons
a minute. Some additional features are that
the handle can rotate a full 360ยบ, and perhaps
my favorite is how easily it comes apart for
servicing. If you need to get inside the pump,
just give the handle a sharp tug and the whole
plunger comes right out. This gives you easy
access to clean it, or add more lubrication
if you need it. Well now you know how to make
a simple PVC hand pump that can be used for
compressing air, pumping water, or creating
a vacuum. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com